both sides of the Atlantic the gate the
legacy gay press said you know
right-wing maniac Marie
you know outrageously misgendered Sam
Smith on radio show all making sure they
didn't mention that I myself am gay we
have extraordinary set of dogmas in our
time whereas dogmatic as any age but it
requires I think you know something to
step back and say what are the dogmas
and I just have decided that it was
worth putting him down the for that I
see most closely gay which is the first
chapter women the second the third is
race and the fourth is trans and we we
basically if I could sum up what I'm
trying to do with this and I'm not sure
it's that I think we are pretending to
know about things we don't know about
and we're pretending not to know about
things we all knew till yesterday and
this these two things simultaneously are
one of the reasons why our societies are
dementing ourselves we pretend to be
exceptionally sure about things like
trans for instance when we really don't
know very much at all about it and I lay
out you know I lay out the most
plausible decent reasonable case for
saying what in what in this claim these
rights claims is is legitimate and
there's something new to think about and
what is it that's just dementing so
that's an example of something we
pretend to be really sure about and we
just don't know almost anything about
yeah and then there are things that we
really do know a lot about or used to
know a lot about till yes they like
relations between the sexes which we
pretend like total mysteries to us so
okay so I love that that as I said for
chapters and it's it's just so simple
it's gay women what intricate race and
trans thank you okay so let's just start
gay that's the title that's it no cheeky
titles no nothing just gay three letters
so I think most people watching this
want gay people too
equally under the law and that is the
way it is and pretty much every Western
society but what you talk about here is
that's not really what the gay movement
is sort of about anymore correct yeah I
mean I think that in each of these cases
there's an argument that what we're
going through is a kind of over
correction in some way I would suggest
that there's always been a problem in
every rights movement of knowing when
you've got to equal and when some people
have overshot so my view is that a lot
of people don't like equal actually they
want to go to better this is really
painful stuff but the extent to which
being gay can be presented as if it's
actually a bit better than being
straight being being black is not just
about being equal it's a bit better than
being white and I get into that in the
race chapter you know and and and and
the example with women is you know that
that's what Christine Lagarde the head
of the IMF did you know that women she
says the financial crash crash at Lehman
Brothers might not have happened if it
had been lame and sisters as if women
are absolutely equal to men and also a
bit better but I think this is a very
dangerous overcorrection in the right
swing and we've gave it's it's got a lot
of a lot of unpleasant connotations
which I go into in the book which I
think were there a night race where they
were from the beginning of the gay
rights movement and I particularly I go
into one thing which I don't think
anyone's written about before which is
what I describe is the divide between
gay and queer and I say that gay is just
you know people who are attracted to
members of their own sex like both you
and I happen to be we're somewhat
over-represented in this conversation
it's very it's very heteronormative our
conversations you see being gay is is
not very interesting beyond that but
there's there's a there's a divide that
was always there within the gay rights
movement which was between people who
are gay and people who are queer and
queer as ice as I describe it is people
who think that being attracted to a
member of their own sex it is merely the
first stage but
bigger campaign such as for instance
bringing down the society or or or
queering the society or bringing down
capitalism or or some of those and and
I'm amazed that this hasn't mean it sort
of focused on before because actually a
lot of the pain that has come from parts
of the gay rights movement over the
years has been precisely the people who
didn't do gay they were doing clear they
were using gay as merely the first thing
to do a bigger political project and
that's common in each of these chapters
as each of them there is a group trying
to do something like that
so then what do we call the gays who are
not trying to destroy Western
civilization and the patriarchy the gays
like us or we're just day that's it
that's so boring is that did you come up
with a better word come on no I'm
sticking with gay on this one but but
it's it's a very important thing to
identify it was always there it was
there Stonewall long words it was there
before indeed that and it's been in in
recent years as I'm very interesting has
happened with the remaining bit of the
gay rights sort of groups which is that
they they have become vulnerable to what
I described as Georgian retirement
syndrome you know there's some George
after slaying the dragon and getting the
acclaim of slaying the dragon staggers
around the land looking for ever more
dragons to slay and can't find them or
find smaller and smaller beasts and
eventually may be found swinging his
sword at Finnair and with fear with
remainders of instance the gay press
this is what they're doing they wish
they'd been at Stonewall they wish that
they'd been fighting back in the day
some of them did but they they get
addicted to the the barricade manner and
that's why we have this very strange
thing and I I really I go straight for
them on this why it turned out the
fences the gay press that remains is
basically a sort of weird social justice
warrior campaigning thing so so much so
that just this past week when my book
came out the main gay magazines in
America and Britain attacked me for
misgendering Sam Smith the pop singer
who came out as non-binary
and I said I'd my viewers which is I
don't think there's any such thing as
non-binary I think it's to say I think
it's it's just absolutely impossible to
determine what the difference is between
saying you're non-binary and just
shouting look at me and I think that's
what he did and I said so and I said I'm
not doing they then I'm not doing all
this all this crap and both both sides
of the Atlantic the gay the legacy gay
press said you know right-wing maniac
Marie
you know outrageously misgender Sam
Smith on radio show all making sure they
didn't mention that I myself am gay and
and the best part I was well the best
part of the whole thing forget that they
don't mention you're gay right because
they want to take away you're a gay card
but that the unless this happened more
than once I saw the video clip of the
radio show that you were doing and the
woman you were arguing against or having
the conversation with she kept saying
that you have to use his proper pronouns
so in it in her own sentence she was
misgendering him yes she accuse me of
bullying him for not using his correct
pronouns because of course I'm in a
great position to bully a
multimillion-pound earning pop star
anyhow that's right this work stuff is
harder than it looks
[Laughter]
this is an example of it the basically
the legacy gay press doesn't have much
to do other than attack gays who it
thinks are are letting the side down by
not being woken up for social justice
warrior enough and I just have boundless
contempt for these people there's a
couple other interesting things that
have happened through an American lens
on this did you happen to see that right
now Peabody jej who is openly gay is
starting to to fuel the wrath of exactly
what you're talking about because I've
seen now the queer magazines or whatever
it is say he's just a heteronormative
man who doesn't identify with being
queer he happens to be married to a man
he has sex with a man I assume but
that's not good enough even for him
who's basically a progressive they still
want the him to live under the booth
that's right well there's there's a
given example in each chapter of
we see the naked Lea political nature of
these movements now the example of
another example before this week one
that I give in the book is Peter Thiel
yeah can Valley a tech entrepreneur
billionaire who is denounced by Advocate
magazine States legacy gay magazine is
denounced by advocate after he comes out
for Trump in 2016 an advocate says Peter
Thiel may sleep with men but in no way
is he gay so like we've all been doing
it wrong all these years and now there's
something else you're meant to be doing
anyhow but but but but this happens on
each of these you know when Kanye West
comes out for Trump
he's denounced in the Atlantic is no
longer being black and Germaine Greer
when she doesn't do the trans one in the
right order is denounced there's no
longer a feminist and you know if if gay
men aren't gay and and Germaine Greer
isn't a feminist and Kanye West isn't
black then what are we really talking
about were these characteristics and I
think what we're talking about is a
naked political push use disgracefully
using identity issues and people's
identity as a way to carry out and
batter a political project if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell